[Music]
thank you
Welcome to our podcast where today we're
going to be discussing the influence of
social media on our lives I'm your host
and with me today is Lisa kusori an
expert in social media and its effects
on society hi everyone I'm excited to be
here today so let's start with the
basics social media has exploded in
popularity over the past decade can you
give us a brief overview of what social
media is and why it's so popular sure
thing social media refers to online
platforms that allow users to create and
share content as well as connect with
others some popular social media
platforms include Facebook Twitter
Instagram and Tick Tock these platforms
have become so popular because they
provide an easy way for people to stay
connected with friends and family as
well as discover new content and ideas
yeah that's true but social media has
also been criticized for its negative
effects on Mental Health as well as its
role in spreading misinformation and
polarizing people can you talk more
about that yes absolutely while social
media can certainly have its benefits
such as connecting with others who share
their interest and providing a platform
for activism it can also be incredibly
harmful for example social media can
contribute to feelings of anxiety and
depression as people constantly compare
themselves to others and feel pressured
to present the perfect image of
themselves online additionally social
media algorithms can recreate Echo
chapters where people only see content
that reinforces their existing beliefs
which can lead to increased polarization
and the lack of understanding between
different groups of people
finally social media can be a breeding
ground for misinformation with false
information spreading quickly and often
with without fact checking and critical
analysis wow those are some really
important points what can we do to
mitigate the negative effects of social
media both individually and as a society
that's a great question I think
an important thing is for individuals to
be aware of how much time they spend on
social media and to take steps to limit
the time if necessary it's also
important to be mindful of the contact
we consume to actively seek out diverse
perspectives and ideas rather than
relying on the algorithm to create our
feeds as a society we need to hold
social media platforms accountable for
the content they allow on their site and
we need to invest in media literacy
education so that people can better
navigate the online world and
distinguish back from fiction those also
really practical suggestions it's clear
that social media is a powerful force in
our lives and we need to be thoughtful
about how we use it
so let's start talking about Tick Tock
which is the most popular social media
amongst teenagers today let's start with
the basics first what is Tick Tock and
why has it become so popular amongst
teenagers Tick Tock is a social media
app that allows users to create and
share short videos set to music or other
audio it has exploded in popularity over
the past few years particularly among
teenagers because it provides an easy
and fun way to create and share content
with others and what are some of the
potential benefits of stick talk for
teenagers well tiktok can certainly have
its benefits for one thing it creative
outlet for young people allowing them to
express themselves and their interests
through videos it can also be a way to
connect with others who share those
interests and to discover new ideas and
perspectives and because Tick Tock is
largely driven by user generated content
it can feel more authentic and relatable
than other forms of media that's all
true but Tick Tock has also been
criticized for its negative effects on
mental health and Body Image as well as
its potential for cyber bullying can you
talk more about that yes unfortunately
tiktok can also be a source of harm for
young people because the app is so
visually focused it can contribute to
feelings of body dissatisfaction and low
self-esteem as users compare themselves
to the often highly created and edited
content they see on the app Additionally
the anonymous nature of the app can make
it easier for people to engage in
cyberbullying or other harmful Behavior
without consequences and because the
algorithm tends to promote content that
is highly engaging it can create a sense
of competition among users to produce
increasingly extreme or provocative
contact in order to get likes and
followers yeah those are some really
important points what can parents and
caregivers do to help teenagers navigate
the potential risk of tick tock one
important thing is for parents to talk
openly and honestly with their kids
about social media and its potential
ethics including on mental health and
Body Image they can also help their kids
to set healthy boundaries around social
media use such as limiting screen time
or taking breaks from the app when it
starts to feel overwhelming finally
parents can encourage their kids to be
critical consumers of social media
content asking questions about where the
content comes from and whether it is
trustworthy or accurate those are some
really practical suggestions it's clear
that Tick Tock can be both a source of
creativity and Community for young
people but also potential source of harm
so what are the best tips you would give
teenagers about using social media well
first and foremost it's important for
teenagers to remember that social media
is not real life the images and the
stories that they can see on social
media often present a highly created and
edited version of reality which can be
very different from the messy
complicated and authentic experiences of
everyday life it's also important for
teenagers to be mindful of their own
social media use and to take steps to
protect their mental health and
well-being such as by limiting screen
time taking breaks from social media and
seeking out positive and uplifting
content yeah I agree with you but what
are some other strategies that teenagers
can use to navigate social media in a
healthy and responsible way another
important tip is for teenagers to be
thought be thoughtful about the
share and the way they interact with
others on social media this means being
kind and respectful to others online
avoiding cyber bullying or other harmful
behaviors and being mindful of the
impact that their words and actions can
have on others it's also a good idea for
teenagers to be critical consumers of
social media content questioning the
sources and the accuracy of information
that they can encounter online and fact
checking as needed let's start talking
about all the generations too because
they are also included in the social
media Circle so what how do you think it
has influenced older Generations
social media has had a significant
impact on older generations with the
increasing use of smartphones and
tablets it has become easier for all
older adults to access social media
platforms they use social media to
connect with friends and family to stay
up to date on news and events and to
access health information yeah that's
very interesting what are some of the
other positive impacts of social media
on the older Generations
social media has many positive impacts
on older Generations it helps them stay
connected with their loved ones
especially who live far away from them
it also provides them with a platform to
share their experiences memories and
opinions social media has also made it
easier for older adults to find support
and resources for their health issues
yeah that's really great to hear however
there must be some negative impacts as
well what are some of the challenges
faced by older adults on social media
yes there are some challenges faced by
older adults on social media one of the
main challenges is the risk of falling
victims to scams and frauds older adults
are often targeted by scammers who take
advantage of their lack of humility with
social media additionally social media
can sometimes exaggerate feelings of
loneliness and isolation among older
adults especially if they are not able
to navigate it easily those are
certainly some very important issues how
can we address these challenges and
ensure that older adults can benefit
from social media without facing these
challenges there are several ways we can
address these challenges firstly we need
to provide older adults with the
necessary education and support to
navigate social media safely this can be
done through Community programs and
workshops secondly social media
platforms need to develop more
user-friendly interface faces or for
older adults this can include features
such as larger font size and simpler
navigation finally we need to raise
awareness about the issue of social
isolation among older adults and promote
initiatives that encourage social
interaction
experiences you have had with social
media I have to say that social media
has brought me closer to people I might
not have connected with otherwise I have
been able to reconnect with old friends
and make new ones through platforms like
Facebook and Twitter it's been amazing
to see how social media can break down
barriers and connect people from all
over the world
however social media also has its
downsides I have found that it can be
easy to get caught up in the highlight
real for other people's lives especially
on platforms like Instagram seeing
perfectly curated feeds and posts can
sometimes make me feel like I'm not
doing enough or or not living my life to
the fullest it's important to remember
that social media is just a snapshot of
someone's life and it's okay to take
things at your own pace so do can you
tell us your most challenging experience
that you have had with social media one
of the most challenging experiences I've
had with social media was dealing with
online harassment as someone who puts
themselves out there on the internet
I've unfortunately been subjected to
hateful comments and messages it can be
incredibly difficult to deal with but I
have found that it's important to
remember that these comments say more
about the person leaving them and they
than they do about me I have also
learned to be more mindful of my own
comments and to never engage with trolls
or bullies
another thing that has come up for me on
social media is the pressure to present
a certain image of persona whether it's
for personal or professional reasons
there can be a temptation to only share
the best parts of our lives and hide the
rest I have found that this can lead to
feelings of inauthenticity and
disconnection it's important to remember
that it's okay to be vulnerable and
share our struggles as well as our
triumphs
so to end this podcast can you talk us
about the mental health how
how has your mental health been with
social media
we have to talk about the impact that
the social media has had on my mental
health so it's not secret the social
media can be addictive and can lead to
feelings of anxiety and depression I
have had to be mindful of my own social
media use and take breaks when necessary
I have also found it helpful to curate
my feeds to include only accounts that
inspire me and uplift Me overall my
experience with social media have been
both positive and negative
it's a powerful tool that has the
potential to connect us and bring us
closer together but it can also cause
stress and negativity the key is to be
mindful of our own social use and to
remember that it's just one part of our
lives
so guys here we are calling the end of
our podcast where we have had our
expertise talk about social media
effects on the younger Generations
thank you for having me it has been a
pleasure to talk about this topic I hope
you have enjoyed it and have a nice day
foreign
[Music]